good morning Hank it's the hottest day
of the year so far and you know what
summertime means it means it's time for
us to use our critical analysis skills
to read with thoughtfulness and depth
hooha nerdfighters so Hank as you know
the current nerdfighter barbing book
club book is none other than the Catcher
in the Rye by JD Salinger get rid arise
JD Salinger's most famous published work
but it's not the only book he ever put
together he also did Franny and Zooey
and nine stories and this book which has
both raised high the roof beam
carpenters and Seymour an introduction
this book has a very interesting
dedication I want to read it to you if
there is an amateur reader still left in
the world or anybody who just reads and
runs I ask him or her with untellable
affection and gratitude to split the
dedication of this book four ways with
my wife and children now Hank let's put
aside the fact that soon thereafter
Salinger left his wife for a 19 year old
girl and hasn't been a particularly good
father to his children and focus on what
Salinger calls the reader who reads and
runs now you hear a lot of people say
that when we try to read books
critically we ruin them or we analyze
them to death or we think about them too
hard and they cease being interesting to
read one of the reasons that metaphor
and symbolism are so important to books
is that they are also important to life
like for example say you're in high
school and you're a boy and you say to a
girl do you like anyone right now that's
not the question you're asking the
question you're asking is do you like me
right now in the exact same way on page
60 of The Catcher in the Rye
when Holden asks the cab driver what
happens to the ducks in the pond when
the pond freezes over he's not asking
about the Ducks he's asking about
himself what happens to me in the dead
of winter when the pond freezes over
that's one of the primary ways that
metaphor works it's a way into the
hardest deepest questions and you don't
have to be able to intellectually grasp
the best metaphors in order for them to
work on you emotionally look Hank I
understand why Salinger might have found
the incessant analysis of his novels
intrusive and painful I understand why
he would appreciate the reader who reads
and runs but this isn't about him
although if you're watching this JD I
think you're awesome
but could you stop doing it with 19 year
olds you're embarrassing yourself you
don't read a book to appease an author
you read a book because you wanna and it
is my strongly held opinion that a book
becomes richer and more vibrant when we
read it closely and think hard about it
to that end Hank in the next two weeks
I'm going to make
videos about Catcher in the Rye one
that's about the first half one that's
about the second half I'm going to be
totally English teacher about it and I
don't care so if you want to read the
book if you could read the first half by
say like next Tuesday like say to the
end of chapter 15 and then we'll talk
about it and then everyone on YouTube
will be all like oh my god critical
analysis is so fun it's like all the
best parts of lisanova puts all the best
parts of smosh and just a few quick
things to think about during the next
week when you're reading the first half
number one in response to the common
criticism that holden caulfield the
narrator The Catcher in the Rye is
unlikable I regret to inform you that
you are also unlikable so am i there's
this like weird but pervasive feeling in
the world of contemporary coming-of-age
fiction that characters ought to be like
either the person you want to be or the
person you want to be with and I'm happy
to acknowledge that Holden Caulfield is
not the guy you want to be or the guy
you want to be with he's not Edward
Cullen but he is the guy you secretly
know yourself to be which I would argue
is in the end much more interesting
number two the red hunting cap be on the
lookout for it number three something
that I think is really important when
you're reading this book is to bear in
mind that there are two stories going on
there's the story that Holden is telling
and there's the place from which he is
telling it now there's the Holden he's
telling the story about and there's the
Holden who is telling the story which I
ultimately think is really important
also I don't know what's wrong with me
I'm doing a lot of Hank green
gesticulations today like I think we all
wish that hadn't happened
so yeah let's read Catcher in the Rye
Hank that was an awesome song about book
eight nerdfighters thank you so much for
your Willie sounds in fact if you would
email your willy sounds to me at sparks
lay up at gmail.com I want to make a
compilation video with Willie doing his
constant head turn because a ton of your
videos made him turn his head and oh if
you live in or near Grand Haven Michigan
I will be there on the afternoon of
Monday July 28th more info in the
sidebar Hank I'll see you later this
week it still smells like my boarding
school